Blake Lively and Ryan Ryan Reynolds
they're in it for the long haul Nancy I
believe it they enjoyed a kid-free
parents night out at the premiere of
Blake's movie a simple fan we got just a
little favor we would ask like no wait
yes can we borrow some looks from your
closet play anything
I made we're girls and we're any kaizen
point last night to red carpet look
I've never seen tails with the train
before she bond she and there you go my
own Christian Louboutin shoes that are
about ten years old now they're older
than that little boy right there they're
older than my funny women
Blake capped off a fashion filled day in
New York with her stunning all-black
ensemble you can say her looks
suited or perfectly because she did five
of them in one day starting with this
floral Gucci two-piece topped with an
over $12,000 but take a Vanetta duster
hours later this color-block look
followed by outfit number three bright
orange and Bottega Veneta and Louboutin
loafers total cost over 4,800 bucks
and finally this straight from the
runway denim suits like without
promoting her new thriller a simple
favor co-starring Anna Kendrick the two
forged a tight friendship on set and a
mighty given Blake's hoodie Ryan
Reynolds a run for his money
brands like an attractive famous
successful man and you need to keep them
on their toes he's got a great lady and
they just need to let him know that
Blake's got options they would do
anything for me issue it she would give
me a kidney
yeah but would she give you one of her
suits legs working on snacking the one
she wore in the movie I'm acting like
I'm wearing them for the press tour that
I may wear them and then stalking them
[Music]
[Applause]